E aí
[Aplausos]
e o Pátria do Progresso
e desperta essa Esperança adormecida e
deixaste adormecer e Lágrimas e
Lamentações
é esta que foi a melodia que magoa
acordada bem toada em cada coração que
hoje hoje são chamados os peridade
porque Tu ouviste a voz de progresso e
abriste a mão de novo antes onde os pena
seu tempo de novo
tô indo para igreja em que passo a passo
construções cada sonho adormecido nesta
fadigada tristeza ou constrói cada sonho
adormecido nesta fatigada tristeza e
ouvidos a voz da Pátria dezembro o
Pátria
o Eric para viver do destino que
erigimos Eric para fazer crescer a beira
Eric para construir cada sonho teu foste
tu tu turu tu tu és à beira de progresso
de Claudia Augusta obrigado